روسيا تبدا نقل اسلحه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا
لا يستبعد تقسيم اوكرانيا بين اوروبا
وروسيا
الخزانه الامريكيه تقول زودت قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان بصواريخ ارض جو
مسؤولون امريكي يقولن بيض ومكارثي يقتربان
من ابرام اتفاق من شانه رفع سقف الديون
لمده عامين
[موسيقى]
طابا صباحكم واهلا بكم الى نشره اخباريه
من العربيه قال رئيس بيلاروسي الكزاندا
بالفعل بنقل اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه من
روسيا الى بيلاروسيا اكد لوكاشينكو في
تصريحات لوسائل الاعلام روسيه ان الاسلحه
النوويه ستكون امنه تماما وبعيده عن ايدي
المخربين بما في ذلك بولندا وفق قوله من
جانب اعتبر الاتحاد الاوروبي ان قرار
بيلاروسيا بنشر اسلحه النوويه الروسيه في
اراضيها يضاعف التوتر ويؤكد ضلوع منسك في
حرب اوكرانيا
تخزين خاصه على اراضيها
ووفقا لوزير الدفاع الروسي فانه تم تسليم
القوات البيلاروسيه نظام الصواريخ
العملياتيه والتكتيكيه اسكندر ام الذي
يمكنه استخدام الصواريخ التقليديه
والنوويه على حد سواء اضافه لذلك فانه تم
اعاده تجهيز مقاتلات 25 للاستخدام المحتمل
للاسلحه النوويه وتحديد نظام وجود منشاه
خاصه لتخزين الاسلحه النوويه في بيلاروسيا
ايضا ومع ان موسكو ترى ان الاجراءات تتم
وفقا للالتزامات الدوليه ولا تنتهك معاهده
عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه الا ان
الانباء تقول ان الصراع بدا ياخذ تصعيدا
خارج الحدود الاوكرانيه والروسيه وتهديدا
نووي رايت المصطفى العربيه
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
اوكرانيا قد تختفي في عمليه تقسيم بين دول
من الاتحاد الاوروبي وروسيا بعد انتهاء
العمليه العسكريه هناك واعتبر ان هذا
الخيار قد يجعل مخاطرا امتلاع حرب عالميه
ثالثه معتدله واضاف المسؤول الروسي ان
الصراع في هذه الحلقه ينتهي بضمانات
معقوله مشيرا الى ان هذا المسار سيكون
بطيئا ويعتمد على التاكل التدريجي للاراضي
الاوكرانيه
في ظهور جديد شكك قائد قوات فاجن الروسيه
بتحقيق هدف بوتين الحرب المتمثل بنزع سلاح
كييف محذرا من ثوره قد تشتعل في داخل
الروسي مزيد من التفاصيل في تقرير التاليه
ربما اصبح هذا الاسم الاكثر شهره خلال
الحرب الاوكرانيه وربما اشهر من بوت نفسه
فالرجل لا يقل عن الاتيان بالجديد
ثم ادلى به يريد الزعيم قوات فاجنر تغيير
نظام روسيا بتطبيق نظام الكوري الشمالي
نظره لها تبريراتها لدى
يجب على روسيا ان تعيش كالنموذج الكوري
الشمالي لعده سنوات وان تغلق جميع الحدود
وان تكف على ان تكون عاطفيه
وفقا لرؤيه الرجل فان ثوره ستجتح روسيا
اذا لم تتحرك النخبه لتدارك الوضع في
البلاد
بينما يموت الناس على الجبهات صهر وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي سفر للاستجمام كل هذه
الانقسامات يمكن ان تنتهي الى ثوره كما
حدث في عام 1917
وفقا لبريجوجل هدف روسيا الى نزع السلاح
اوكرانيا جاء بنتائج عكسيه نتائج قد تزداد
لتصل البر الروسي
اذا كانت لديهم بشكل مجازي 500 دبابه في
بدايه العمليات الخاصه فلديهم الان 5000
دبابه كيف قمنا بتجريد اوكرانيا من السلاح
الان اتضح اننا على العكس من ذلك يعرف
الجحيم كيف عسكرنا اوكرانيا
عاد هذا وذاك بريجوجين لم ينسى خصومه في
روسيا رغم هجمات القاسيه التي شنها عليهم
خلال معركه باغموت هجمات انهاها باطراء
للاوكرانيين فهؤلاء بنظره اذكياء ومنظمون
جدا وقد يصلون البر الروسي من جزيره القرم
وفي مناطق المعارق شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا
تنتشر ساحه تدريب المقاتلين الروس ويخصص
الجيش الروسي ارضيات قريبه من المعركه
ليتاقلم المقاتلون الجدد مع واقع الحرب
والمواجهه ضد الجيش الاوكراني وبشكل
افتراضي
هذا المكان هو لتمرين المستجدين من الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق ان كان من الدبابات او
من حتى الاسلحه المتوسطه او الاسلحه
الخفيفه هذه دبابه تمرنا عليها الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق واصابه الاهداف في هذه
المواقع المنتشره في مناطق مختلفه ان كان
في باخموت وان كان فيكا او مارنكا في هذه
المقاطعه وهذا الاقليم بالفعل هنا عمليات
التدريب تجريب من حولي كما نرى عدد من
الدبابات
والرماء الذين يحاولون التدريب اكثر على
اصابه الاهداف لمصلحه الجيش الروسي في هذا
المكان يتمرن المستجدون من الجيش الروسي
ان كان بعد التعبئه الجزئيه او حتى من
المتطوعين او من تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
هذه القذائف التي تطلق من الاليات
الثقيله هنا تملا المكان خلفي هناك دبابات
وايضا في هذه الناحيه دبابات تتمرن على
اطلاق النار كما اننا نشاهد على الارض هذه
قطع ايضا من القذائف هذه كلها هذه قطع
للتدريب يعني الجنود يتدربون على الاطلاق
واصابه الاهداف في ذلك المحور البعيد هناك
اهداف يجب اصابتها من قبل المتمرنين
والمتدربين اما في هذه الناحيه فنرى
هنا المتدربين على الاطلاق من الاسلحه
الوسطى وليست الخفيفه ايضا يتمرنون على
اصابه الاهداف في هذا الموقع التدريبي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
قالت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه لمجموعه
فاجن الروسيه زودت قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان بصواريخ ارض جو لقتال الجيش
السوداني وحضرت الخزانه الامريكيه في بيان
من ان دعم فاجنر لقوات دعم السريع يساهم
في نزاع مسلح طويل الامد سيؤدي لمزيد من
الفوضى في المنطقه
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه بان اليه
مراقبه اتفاق وقف اطلاق نار في السودان
رصدت عده انتهاكات للاتفاق بما في ذلك
استخدام المدفعيه وطائرات الحربيه
والمسيارات من جهاته قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ماتيو ميلر قال في
بيان ان بلاده تواصل الاتصال مع طرفي
الصراع مشيرا الى واشنطن ستستخدم جميع
الادوات الممكنه لتحميل الطرفين مسؤوليه
الصراع الحالي الذي تشهده البلاد
اكد الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم البديوي حرصا المجلس على دعم استعاده
الامن والسلام والاستقرار في اليمن وشدد
خلال لقائه وزير الخارجيه اليمني احمد عوض
بن مبارك على الموقف الثابت لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي بشان دعم جهودي انهاء الازمه
اليمنيه من خلال حل السياسي والحفاظ على
وحده اليمن وسيادته من جهته اشاد وزير
الخارجيه اليمني بدور دول الخليج خاصه
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه لتنفيذ مشروعات
تنمويه لتوفير الحياه الكريمه لليمنيين
اعلنت الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد في تركيا
دعم مرشح رئاسه المعارض كمال كلتشتار
اوغلو في جوله الاعاده في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه دون تسويته وقال مسؤولون من حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي وحلفائها من حزب اليسار
الاخضر انهم يسعون الى التغيير في جوله
الاعاده ولا يقبلون ببقايا الدهان شيرين
الى انهم سيصوتون لصالح انهاء نظام الرجل
الواحد
الى ذلك قالت وكاله رويتر الاكراد
المعارضين لرئيس التركي رجال تايبردوغان
يخشون من ان فوزه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
قد يعزز القمع ضدهم وينظر الى الاكراد
الذين يشكلون نحو خمس سكان تركيا على انهم
ربما يكونوا عنصر الحسم بالنسبه للمعارضه
التي تامل بانهاء حكم اردوغان بالنسبه
لبعض الناخبين الاكراد فهم لم يواجهوا
مخاطر اكبر مع تشديد اردوغان نبرته
القوميه في محاوله لكسب اصوات المزيد من
الناخبين قبل جوله الاعاده الاحد المقبل
وفاز حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي بنسبه 61% في
ديار بكر في الانتخابات البرلمانيه في
منتصف الشهر الجاري الى انه حصل على 8.9%
في عموم ارجاء تركيا
الاكراد والخشيه من فوز اردوغان وسط تصاعد
النبره القوميه قبيل جوله الاعاده
الانتخابات التركيه واحتماليه فوز اردوغان
الذي اثار قلقا في صفوف الاكراد خوفا من
تصعيد عسكري الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد
تؤكد دعمها للمعارضه التركيه لكنهم لم
يذكروا بالاسم
النظام الغريب الذي اسسه اردوغان وشركائه
سبب المشاكل المجتمعيه التي نعاني منها ما
سيتم تصويت عليه في 28 من مايو هو مدى
امكانيه استمرار هذا النظام الغريب من
عدمه
تحول في المواقف في سنواته الاولى من
السلطه منح اردوغان المزيد من الحقوق
للاكراد والغى القيود المفروضه على
استخدام اللغه الكرديه عام 2015 وبعد
انهيار وقف اطلاق النار غير اردوغان مساره
السياسي
وشنت السلطات التركيه حمله قمع ادت الى
اعتقال الالاف من الاكراد
نشرب مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
على ذمه اعلام امريكي مساعدو ترامب نقل
وثائق سريه قبل مداهمه المحققين مقره في
فلوريدا
اهلا بكم دانت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
اختبار ايران لصاروخ بلسيا بعيد المدى
معتبره انه انتهاك لقرارات مجلس الامن
ومدعاه للقلق في ضوء التوسع المتواصل
البرنامج النووي الايراني ياتي هذا بعد
اعلان الجانب الايراني اجراء تجارب اطلاق
صاروخ باليسي بنجاح
الى ذلك دعا النائب الالماني عن حزب
الاتحاد المسيحي الديمقراطي المعارض دع
حكومه بلاده الى ممارسه ضغوط اضافيه على
ايران واكدان ان طهران باتت على مسافه
قصيره من تقصيب يورانيوم بدرجه تسمح لها
بالحصول على السلاح النووي
انا قلق للغايه من الطريق الذي تسلكه
ايران انا شخصيا ممنوع من دخول ايران
بقرار اصدرته السلطات هناك لانني وجهت
انتقادات للتصرفات في وجه المحتجين نصف
الشعب الايراني تحت الضغط اتحدث عن النساء
هناك عشره الاف امراه في السجون والمئات
قتلنا وفتيات المدارس تعرضنا للتسمم
النساء لا حريه لهن في ايران ومن جهه اخرى
نرى ان ايران لا تقبل بحق اسرائيل في
الوجود وهي تعمل على تطوير قنبله نوويه
وهذا امر مثير للقلق بشكل كبير
اتهمت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج تهمت الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بشن حمله تضليل بعدما قالت
واشنطن وشركائها الغربيون ومايكروسوفت ان
جهه فاعله سيبرانيه مدعومه من بكين تسللت
الى شبكات امريكيه للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه
اطلعنا على التقرير واود ان اقول انه
تقرير عدلناه معا مع نقص خطير في الادله
وعدم المهنيه ولا توجد احترافيه كما
لاحظنا ان هناك تقارير مماثله صدرت في وقت
واحد من قبل الوكالات الحكوميه كوكاله
الامن القومي الامريكيه واخرى ذات صله في
المملكه المتحده واستراليا وكندا
ونيوزيلندا وغيرها من الدول من الواضح
انها حمله تظليل جماعيه من قبل الولايات
المتحده لتعبئه البلدان في تحالف العيون
الخمس لاغراض جيوسيه
قال مسؤولنا امريكي ان رئيس جو بايدن
ورئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكايتي يقتربان
من ابرام اتفاق من شانه رفع سقف الديون
لمده عامين مع كبح الانفاق على معظم
البنود بخلاف الجيش وقدامى المحاربين من
جهاته قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كافن
مكارسي ان المفاوضين سيواصلون العمل
للتواصل الاتفاق بشانه سقف الديون مضيفا
بان الامر صعب لكن العمل سيتواصل حتى
انجازه
كانت لدي محادثات عده مثمره مع الرئيس
مجلس النواب كيف المقافي وطلبت منه
استمرار المباحثات التي تحرز تقدمها واؤكد
ان التخلف عن سداد الدين ليس خيارا مطروحا
الشعب الامريكي يستحق ان يعلم ان مدفوعات
الخدمات الاجتماعيه ستستمر وان المستشفيات
ستظل مفتوحه وسنواصل التقدم الاقتصادي
الذي حققناه التخلف عن سداد الدين سيضع كل
هذا في خطر اعضاء الكونجرس يدركون كل ذلك
وهم متفقون على انه لا يكون هناك تخلف عن
سداد الدين
انه يوم اخر من المفاوضات بين الجمهورين
والديمقراطيين والبيت الابيض مع بعض الامل
بالتوصل الى اتفاق يوم الخميس
اطلب الموافقه بالاجماع على انه بعد رفع
الجلسه ان يعود مجلس النواب الى الاجتماع
غدا
كان هذا افضل مؤشرا على ان الاتفاق ممكن
حيث كان من المنتظر ان يغادر اعضاء
الكونغرس يوم الخميس في اجازه تذكار
الموتى على ان يعودوا له طلب منهم ذلك
وزاد من معدلات التفاؤل قول رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مكارثي انه تم تحقيق تقدم في
مفاوضات يوم الاربعاء في البيت الابيض
عملنا لما بعد منتصف الليل وكان يوما جيدا
وحققنا بعض التقدم وما زالت هناك بعض
المشاكل العالقه وطلبت من الطاقه من
متابعه العمل على مدار الساعه
ليس من الواضح بعد ما هي تفاصيل الاتفاق
المحتمل وما هي المصروفات التي سيوافق
الديمقراطيون على اقتطاعها مقابل رفع سقف
الدين وهم حتى صباح الخميس ما زالوا
غاضبين ويتحدثون عن دعم المحاربين القدامى
وبرامج المساعدات
المحاربون القدامى يواجهون مشكله بسبب
الجمهوريين الذين اخترعوا مشكله سقف الدين
ومع هذه التناقضات بدات الاسواق تشعر اكثر
بالضغوطات وبدات تتسرب معلومات من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه عن انها ستدفع لاصحاب
السندات اولا لو لم يتوصل الطرفان الى
اتفاق
لدى جمعيات السندات والاسواق لمتابعه
العمل وتبادل السندات والتصرف وكانه ليس
هناك مشكله بدا الاطراف بتحقيق تقدم ولكن
وزاره الخزانه والاسواق تستعد للسيناريو
الاسوا والسيناريو الاسوا هو عدم دفع
الدوله للاجور والمعاشات عند ذلك لا احد
يعرف كيف تسير الاسواق في الغنم العربيه
[موسيقى]
واجهه حاكم فلوريدا بدايه متعثره مع تدشين
حملته للفوز بقياده الحزب الجمهوري نحو
سباق رئاسه الامريكي قد اختار روند سانتوس
منصه تويتر لاطلاق حملته بصحبه الملياردير
ايلون ماسك الى انه واجه العديد من
الاعمال والاعطال الفنيه ليحترم بذلك
خصماه بايضا من الحزب الديمقراطي والترامب
من الحزب الجمهوري الفرصه ويسخران منه
بدايه متعثره للرونديسانتس الطامح في
هزيمه ترامب وقياده الحزب الجمهوري في
سباق الرئاسه الامريكيه العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
ديسانتس اختار تويتر لتدشين حملته فانهار
الموقع وتعثر الاتصال
وانقطاع متواصل في الاتصال
بحب الموقع بالضغط الهائل على الشبكه
وكثره المعجبين ترامب ساخره من ذلك وعلق
على منصته
مفتاحيه الاحمر اكبر وافضل واقوى ويعمل
جيدا مفتاحك لا يعمل بايظ انتهز الفرصه
ايضا نشر رابطا لحملته وكتب هذا الموقع
يعمل
لقد صمدنا عندما تم تهديد الحريه اطهرنا
اننا نستطيع ويجب اعاده احياء امريكا نحن
بحاجه الى الشجاعه للقياده والقوه للفوز
انا راندي سانتوس اعلن ترشحي الانتخابات
الرئاسه لقياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى
ورغم البدايه المتعثره تقنيا لديسانس الا
انه تمكن من جمع مليون دولار في ساعه
واحده لدعم حملته الانتخابيه ما يعني انه
لن يكون منافسا سهلا لا للترامب ولا لبعد
افادت وسائل اعلام الامريكيه ان مساعدي
رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب نقل
وثائق السريه قبل يوم من زياره محققي مكتب
تحقيقات الفيدرالي ومدعي عام فيدرالي
لمقره في ولايه فلوريدا اضافت المصادر وان
المحققين يعتبرون ذلك امرا مشبوها واذا ما
تاكد التفاصيل الجديده فان ذلك ربما يساعد
في توجيه الاتهام للترامب
اشتاحت عاصفه ترابيه المناطق مختلفه في
العراق وغطت الاتربه والغبار السماء
العاصمه العراقيه بغداد سجلت وزاره الصحه
عددا من حالات الاختناق في محافظات بغداد
كركوك صلاح الدين والانبار
[موسيقى]
وفي الجزائر تسببت الفيضانات التي خلفتها
الامطار الرعديه بوفاه طفلين في ولايتي
البلاد وتبازه المجاوره للعاصمه الجزائر
كما تسببت في خسائر بالعديد من المرافق
وخاصه المدارس
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه النشره لم يبقى الا ان نذكر
بالعناوين
روسيا تبدا نقل اسلحه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا
لا يستبعد تقسيم اوكرانيا بين اوروبا
وروسيا
الخزانه الامريكيه تقول انفاجنر زودت قوات
دعم السريع في السودان بصواريخ ارض جو
مسؤولون امريكي يقول مكارسي يقتربان من
ابرام اتفاق من شانه رفع سقف الديون لمده
عامين
ولمتابعه المزيد من الملفات والاخبار
والتحليلات زر موقعنا العربي الى هنا
تنتهينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات